les prêts pour une interview première
fois ben oui c'est la première fois que
l'on fait sécher par agent ne serait
jamais prêt premier souvenir en cinq ans
cheminée j'ai sorti du ventre de maman
il y avait plein de gens blancs qui me
regardait en veillant à ma maman et
florennes ses frères au premier péché le
premier fait ce n'est pas ma maman elle
était abonnée au quintal thermolactyl de
damart et un jour je les feuilleter en
cachette comme sa cuisine connu
j'ai des pensées impures soit première
boum
j'aime pas mais dans la première boucle
j'ai vomi
pourquoi parce qu'un mec sympa et mon ex
boivent du whisky coca sont qu'ils
avaient oublié même du clan 15
le premier rideau - madeleine point les
pommes oui les premiers fleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors la chandelle ilham et l heure mais
lisa mais taylor d'aujourd'hui estime
première cuite tamanrasset cessé à
droite ou à gauche là
[ __ ] monde
expériences sexuelles
c'était avec une boîte de cirage tous
les antilles mais matin chez un arbre et
chanteurs et chanteuses pine beach un
organe
bravo
premier voyage d'un premier voyage en
soulignant que c'était ainsi jeté par la
fenêtre
c'est le tout premier est ton premier
choix bon alors ça c'est un jour mes
parents ils vont garder là je pense que
oui c'est un genre j'ai une randonnée
avec un camarade dans la forêt et on
avait décidé d'attraper des crapauds
pour les faire fumer
steven problème c'est qu'on n'a pas
attrapé crapaud quoi ouais c'est moi et
il en est fier
je fais mon premier succès c'est un jour
j'ai réussi un personnel marchand de
journaux de novembre quant aux sept
années 30 on sait le journal où tu vois
tout ce qu'il ya dedans les dames et des
[ __ ] première interview la tv
interview la télé instance était nulle
part ailleurs
avec monsieur philippe gildas et je
tiens à lui rendre hommage parce que
c'est un grand monsieur
enfin non état dernières volontés ça
serait quoi beaucoup moins je peux venir
bah si tu veux oui laurent temps de la
monarchie comme ça c'est moi quelqu'un
prendrait il pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu